you guys go there a scale of one to five
how pleasurable is that five
jackpot was there ever a moment in any
of the exercises you were doing when you
thought wait can we do this can we film
this will this work you know in our
first netflix show we push the boundary
pretty far do you think by being sort of
explicit about it we can help women
reframe what that experience is yes so i
think netflix were actually relieved
that you know this scene is pretty tame
we're having sex this is a show about
sex we're gonna talk about zach in
gweneth's six-part netflix series sex
love and goop which drops thursday she
helps arm real-life couples with tool
kits for enhancing their sex lives and
intimacy okay let's bring out a couple
little pleasure items these are my
wolverine claws how did you find these
couples who were so willing to disrobe
in many ways there's so many people who
really love their partner and then are
really struggling with the intimate
aspect of their relationship so
people were willing and then i'm just so
in awe
of these couples who showed up with so
much bravery i do want to ask you one
personal question okay since this show
is very personal
what's something that puts gweneth in
the mood
[Laughter]
i mean have you seen a picture of my
husband that's like you know it doesn't
take much that would be husband of three
years brad falchuk he even hangs out
with gwyneth's ex chris martin as the
co-parent 17 year old apple and 15 year
old moses you have two teenagers and i
sure do how do you talk to your kids
about sex you know i mean teenagers are
never going to want to talk to their
parents about sex ever so i sort of
follow their lead and um luckily in
middle school they had a very thorough
sex education so the school handled you
know the kind of birds and the bees
parts and then i'm there for any
questions or but the questions are
pretty minimal like i think they go to
their friends more the 49 year old is
also on a mission to help other women
get in the mood she's launching a new
goop supplement so the supplement is to
help
support female
you know
enjoyment thank you you also talk about
aging and finding acceptance what work
are you doing in that area i do think
like if we do take care of ourselves the
aging is a little bit easier so i would
just recommend staying hydrated and and
exercise and staying away from processed
foods i think it's really also about how
we feel internally right and it's like
another unfortunate part of aging is we
get exhausted and
you know our our joints start to hurt
and it's there's a long list hormonal
fluctuations and on and on
i try to you know like um not not become
a burden on the family with it you know
like i'm gonna go in the other room and
have a meltdown about something and then
i'll be right back
[Music]
you